we have a nutrition crisis on our hands
we need more fresh food closer to cities
new ways of growing food that conserve
soil and we shouldn't just keep spending
money the way we have been today I'm
speaking with Ken Cook the president and
co-founder of environmental working
group at least 200 million Americans
have past chemicals in their finished
drinking water right out of the tap at a
level that we consider unsafe we cover
specific ways all of us can make better
more informed decisions about the
choices we make at the market taking
advantage of the many resources and
guides that ewg provides it was an honor
to host a conversation I think you will
find quite edifying there are definitely
things you can do personally to
dramatically reduce your personal
exposure to these
chemicals like what are we supposed to
actually pay attention to well I
[Music]
mean today's episode is brought to you
by the awesome organizations that make
this show
[Music]
possible why don't we just establish
what the environmental working group is
and and what your mandate is so people
understand the work that you do that
I've admired and respected um for quite
some time so it's really great to have
you here oh it's it's my pleasure I
means a lot to hear that rich thanks
well uh we're 30 years old for 30 years
ewg has been around uh doing a couple of
things one we've always had a strong
science Bas whether we were looking at
pesticides in food or pollutants in air
or soil erosion we work on a wide range
of issues we have about 75 people on the
staff a lot of scientists A lot of
lawyers communication Specialists
database programmers and the whole
organization really initially was built
to bring
fresh analysis to policy
discussions we wanted to shape how
pesticides were regulated in Washington
how air pollution was regulated how you
know we were incentivizing farmers to do
the right thing like grow things
organically that our whole world at that
time this is again 30 years ago right
their early 90s our worldview was about
public policy and over time a couple of
things happened one policy stopped
working m
everyone who casts a glance at
Washington can see that for some time
we've been in a real paralysis is there
a rationale for that that you can point
to in the environmental realm there
definitely is and I think what it comes
down to is in the the 70s and early 80s
uh right up to uh you know the 1990
Clean Air Act the environmental
Community was extremely successful going
to congress with factual information
about pollution problems the need for
regulation the need to protect
Wilderness areas the the whole range of
environmental
issues
and Congress passed laws laws turned
into regulations industry had to comply
and the citizens and consumers
benefited but after a while the immune
system kicked in and this these
regulated communities you know Big Oil
big food Big Egg uh utilities and so
forth and the push back really started I
feel when when George Bush I first
signed the Clean Air Act in 1990 my good
friend Bill Riley who was EPA
administrator at the time made that made
that happen and I feel like there was a
really strong response from you know
powers that um really rang from the Koch
brothers who were concerned about what
impact it might have on their industry
to utilities like we don't do we really
want Republican president signing
environmental regulation types of laws
big powerful sweeping laws like the
Clean Air Act and I think you saw from
then on a huge investment in everything
that could be managed to shape public
policy more money spent on lobbying more
campaign contributions more lobbyists I
mean to go in some of these rooms that
we go into Now Rich and Washington where
we're fighting over something like the
farm bill that's before us this year
that will reauthor R will freshen up
modernize the the law that was last
passed 5 years ago it'll set subsidies
it'll set food stamp rules it'll do all
kinds of stuff these rooms are now
dominated by these super powerful groups
the Farm Bureau the commodity
organizations the big food companies
they have a throw weight that's Way
Beyond what the public interest
Community has and so what we saw
beginning in the 90s as the pace of
environmental laws slowed down we
weren't passing them we couldn't pass
the Clean Air Act today yeah we couldn't
pass The Endangered Species Act today I
don't think we could establish EPA today
if Nixon hadn't establish that's
frightening so the strangle hold that K
Street lobbying efforts have upon um our
elected officials who are elected by
Dent of Camp campaign Finance laws that
uh allow these organizations
them and an electorate that's based on
Jerry Mander districts creates creates
uh you know stagnation or a paralysis
against the kind of progress and
Innovation that I would assume most
consumers want and and most likely these
elected representatives would choose you
know otherwise for yeah you know I think
that there's there's the two realities
one is the reality that you you face
when you meet get to know some of these
members Republicans and Democrats alike
where they basically are saying look I
I'd like to do it but I can't I even go
so far as say I agree with you but it's
not where the party is the most serious
lock and I say this as an organization
that a assiduously Works to be
bipartisan um and works with you know
conservative groups in Washington uh it
really it really comes down to uh a lock
on the ideology in the Republican party
that that it has to be against
regulation has to be against um climate
change has to be against you know
constraining agriculture or chemical
Industries they bake that in in the
primary process before you even get a
run for the office in the general
election and that's the change I've
noticed I mean we used to lobby with
Republican Senators and members in the
you know 80s and 90s and you you you
know they they wanted the same things
that Democratic colleagues wanted they
sometimes they wouldn't go as far there
were conservative Democrats that didn't
want to go as far but the the dynamic in
Washington became so so Frozen so
paralyzed but then the second thing that
happened so first is the paralysis that
shaped the organization the other thing
that changed us in the opposite
direction that makes it a good time to
be an environmentalist is all the energy
that's you know been freed up in the
private sector to get things done with
without waiting for government
regulation so it's it's now the case
that you know consumers learn about
things directly on the internet they
matched with consumer enthusiasm for
this information and a free a more free
flowing source source of of that
information to empower the consumer look
at the people that you through your work
have empowered um you know that
you're teaching people encouraging
people shaping their world view with
information that they've freely come to
you requesting and so much better off in
terms of following your advice than they
would be if they waited for the
government to tell them what to do right
I mean the whole area of
nutrition uh to me has uh been frozen
for many years by the politics in DC
but around that have come voices like
yours and others authentic voices
evidence-based voices who are showing
people another way sometimes drives food
companies crazy drives the nutrition
sector the you know formal uh profession
a little crazy but you know I was
debating someone the other day and uh
nutritionist who said we're making too
much of these pesticides in
food uh maybe we're scaring people off
by ewg talking about pesticides and
fruits and vegetables I said well you
know we we really do try and tell people
the most important thing is to eat
fruits and vegetables and the pesticides
are the second thing to worry about but
right don't don't substitute an Apple
for a Twinkie but my my comeback was
where has your profession been that
we're still at the place where Americans
aren't eating nearly enough fruits and
vegetables that's been the mainstream
nutrition community's AOW goal is to
diversify what's on your plate uh you
know eat a not entirely plant-based diet
but invest your nutritional energy much
more into a plant-based diet and it
hasn't it hasn't happened the forces
that are making that happen are forces
like you and others who are out there
basically saying hey look there's plenty
of evidence here and if you can't get
the school system to respond you can't
get the hospitals to respond to the
other institu tions there's still a way
to make this happen and and it's
happening around them so we found that
with personal care products we we rate
them we found great companies wanting to
do the right thing uh we found it with
organic food the organic food sector has
exploded now it's a60 billion doll
industry when when I first started
working on it back in the 70s and 80s
you you know you had to you you really
had to hunt for organic food you usually
ended up at a co-op yeah you're in a
weird macro biotic sort of you know you
know sawdust floored you know Hipp you
know kind of place like that that's
where you had to go to get your you know
quote unquote like healthy food and and
it looked like hell usually I mean it
was a far cry from you know Awan yeah
exactly and now you know um there there
are some shortcomings with the the
organic standard of course but uh you
know you've got organic fruits and
vegetables in every major grocery store
uh some stores have their own in-house
Brands Kroger Safeway others um it's
just that that all came about from the
outside that was not the nutrition
profession guiding the way this all came
about because people wanted to live
different Senator Booker says uh change
doesn't uh come from Washington it comes
to Washington so all of this consumer
enthusiasm obviously shifts markets over
time and there's something to be
obviously celebrated about that all of
the information that's empowering people
with these tools and the work that you
do that that is very specifically
telling people stay away from this
here's a better option all these you
know kind of um reports that you
generate that help guide these choices
are amazing but I think it's still
important to you know reestablish a
level of trust in the institutions and
in these regulatory bodies because a lot
of that consumer
uh enthusiasm is the result of a loss of
of of trust in the FDA the USDA the EPA
yeah absolutely you know you're a
watchdog on these organizations and
you're also a partner with them to try
to produce change but that lack of that
lack of trust isn't great either like
that has to that has to be somehow
repaired I completely agree it's a
crisis um and it you know it predates
the current situation where you have you
know some some pretty wild uh conspiracy
ideas that have gripped a big part of
the population uh it predates that and I
I think the wearing down of that trust
tends to benefit special interests um if
the government can't be trusted to do
the right thing uh maybe we should stop
the government from doing anything at
all and you're certainly right I mean we
we when we saw that the Regulatory and
legislative process was slowing down and
not getting us the results and saw the
potential for going you know working
with the private sector directly we were
excited about that but we've never given
up you know we spend our lobbying limit
every year yeah uh because we you're a
lobbying Endeavor yourself you're just a
nonprofit version of your funding is is
contributions and grants I'll tell you
exactly where it comes from we get it we
have about a $14 million budget uh about
3 million of that comes from uh directly
online from donors who give maybe 20 25
bucks on average um about three or four
million comes from foundations uh
another three or four million comes from
uh major donors people of means who
write checks above $1,000 uh and then a
certain amount of it but not very much
comes from our licensing and
certification program where we we feel
like we have to charge the companies we
can't really charge our our donors to to
help a company make money but so we we
charge a fee to review their products
review the ingredients and uh put our
mark on it it's a a modest amount of
money but it's it it it pays for the
scientists who are doing the work
instead of having to go to a donor and
say hey can you help this company out
they want to bring a new product to
Market we can't that's not really kosher
so so that's the you know that's the
balance for us it's we're still a small
organization but we you know we're
constantly on Capitol Hill we're in SA
ramento we're trying to hold these
political leaders these government
officials accountable and we can never
give up on that even as we see that the
private sector can kind of go things
along I'll tell you I'll tell you what
happened with personal care products we
for years we built this database people
can go to online and look at the safety
of personal care products It's called
Skin Deep it's the ewg site we have
about 880,000 plus products that we rate
on there and we rate thousands of
ingredients in those products and we put
it together as brilliant woman who
started uh the process at ewg 20 almost
20 years ago Jane hoolan she said if we
can show Congress how few regulations
are really affecting these ingredients
some of which are
worrisome maybe you know make policy
change and some of one of the
ingredients was these phalates and there
was a CDC study that showed these were
toxic chemicals showing up in the blood
of women of childbearing age and that's
what really got Jane's attention and the
CDC scientist said well they might be
coming from personal care products and
we're like what is that an environmental
Source now we had never thought of it
rich we' never we thought of air
pollution coming out of smoke stacks or
or or tail pipes or pollution coming off
a farm field or you know wafting off of
a pesticide
spray no personal care that's what they
said said and so it was worrisome enough
for them to study it so we built the
database and it shook up the industry
but not in the way ex we exactly
expected we weren't thinking at least I
wasn't thinking at the time that we'd
start attracting consumers we thought we
were going to take this pile of evidence
up to Capitol Hill and they were going
to say you know you're right we haven't
really tightened regulations here since
the new deal maybe maybe it's time for a
for a makeover of the personal care
products industry for the makeup
industry and but when we started seeing
all these people coming onto the site
and now we get about a thousand people
an hour who just go to that one property
skin deep and look up ingredients look
up they they go through their makeup
case they when we saw that happening we
thought well that that's interesting
that's starting to shape the market it's
showing up in Amazon reviews we were not
a consumer facing group at that point we
were still policy nerds marching to the
agencies in the hill and then the next
thing we knew we started getting calls
from companies saying hey you know I
rate really well in your in your
database um I'm using all clean stuff
thank you I'm glad to have the rating it
was we you know we rated them no matter
what they weren't giving us any money
and they said and they said
uh you know we want to make sure we stay
green let us know if you're going to
make any changes we want to stick with
your program it's it's become our
marketing and and then the industry
started saying internally well maybe we
shouldn't negotiate with these folks on
policy issues because a lot of our
companies are starting to say this is a
this is an important source of
information for our market for our
consumers so the whole thing turned out
to be a you know sort of a a backwards
way to go into the policy process where
we started lobbying
with with food companies on food issues
we started lobbing with personal care
products on our agenda I mean we you
know we met in the middle but it it was
progress and that's how we're passing
laws now in California we're sitting
down with the private sector first and
saying hey we we just banned four
sketchy food ingredients it'll well
it'll if Newsome signs the bill it's on
his desk now four sketchy food additives
that should have been banned long ago
and are banned in Europe but FDA hasn't
done a thing right now they're going to
be banned and the food industry by and
large came along and said okay we can
live with that that's so interesting
yeah along with this pivot of your your
organization to be more consumer facing
with these reports that basically inform
these decisions yeah it's fantastic yeah
and then they and those same consumers
they'll send emails they make phone
calls they're on our email list now
right so we've kind of found another way
to empower them and uh the people who
are most engaged with our website are
often the people who are most engaged to
say yeah I'll I'll call Sacramento I'll
call my member of Congress in Washington
yeah with respect to so many of these
products particularly in the beauty and
and cosmetic space as you were sharing
that I was reflecting on um my friend
Greg Renfrew who's been on the podcast
founder of beauty count Beauty counter
and she's just an amazing you know kind
of warrior in the space and her story of
realizing when she had babies that there
were thousands of chemicals that were
finding their way into all of these
products and it was essentially
unregulated
yeah there's no burden of proof on the
corporate entities to establish any
level of safety it's a sort of react and
see approach where if something
percolates up and there seems to be you
know a a flare of um something negative
happening with as a result of the use of
these products then we'll take a look to
me the burden of proof is upside down
there should be a burden of proof on
these companies to establish some agreed
upon level of safety before they find
their way into these products that is
not the case um so my the first part of
my question is is that a pipe dream or
is there a way to work towards that and
then secondarily to that it creates an
incentive structure that's also upside
down where there's no incentive for
these companies to invest in safety um
quite the opposite yeah don't study you
might until you address that it's sort
of like you're dealing with symptoms but
that's the root cause of so much of the
the harm is just the way the the whole
establishment is constructed from the
get-go oh totally no well this is again
the the personal care industry and there
are lots of them and and you when you
talk to you know regular people it's
hard for them to believe in many cases
that something that's on the Shelf at
CVS that you're going to put on your
baby shampoo or skin care or whatever
much less on your own skin that is going
to penetrate your skin we find these
chemicals we've tested people for them
they are in your blood uh hard for
people to believe that that happens
without government approval right of the
ingredients or the final products and
neither one of them have as you say
pre-market safety testing what Greg did
and it it was inspiring to us we've
worked with Greg is speaking at our our
conferences later this year we consider
her one of our dear friends um and in
Inspiration you know when Greg was first
talking about beauty counter uh and we
were changing not exchanging notes on
what we did we you know we basically
said look we will help you any way we
can with your standard but the the thing
she did was she said I'm going to set
for my company these tough standards
there's certain things there's no way
I'm going to use it even though it's the
standard in the industry everyone uses
it um I'm going to go beyond that and
try and formulate to even safer
standards the fact that she did that and
made it work uh and she's not alone I
mean my our board member Michelle feifer
did the same thing with fine fragrance
um amazing accomplishment because that's
a that's a category of personal care
product that is completely a black box
you put the word fragrance on a personal
care product or a cleaning product and
that can hide hundreds of chemicals and
Michelle said I'm going to put that
name and then I'm going to tell
everybody what all the chemicals are and
no one she could hardly find anyone to
work with her these fragrance houses
were like you're crazy it's crazy that
you can just put fragrance on there and
say no more say no more that's it that's
in law that's enshrined in law still but
you know um people like Greg Michelle
shazi vzam I mean so many other of these
brilliant um entrepreneurs that's who we
started hearing from and I'm thinking
you know
um they're aiming for the same thing
that I'm aiming for they just happen to
be
for-profit so I'm going to I want to
take a chance and start getting to know
them better and talking to them and you
know it's not like uh we're making
products ourselves we're we're basically
taking a look at their products and
saying hey you know this is this is
really good stuff this meets our
toughest standard and that I think is
what is so exciting about being an
environmentalist now it's happening in
energy with rooftop soul of course the
utilities are fighting back it's
happening with Organic and food and now
you know it advances and to make organic
even tougher the food industry is
freaked out about it they don't like the
idea of something springing up that they
can't buy or control that would start to
shape consumer perceptions about all the
rest of the food it's happening in
personal care it's happening in cleaners
so mainly in consumer facing sectors
there is this real potential now to
Drive change deeper and faster with
respect to health and I think we'll get
there with sustainability we'll get
there with plastics um that consumer
awareness that cultural awareness could
not be stopped in the way that big
industry was stopping regulation and law
you can't stop the culture right and
this realization that you could work
hand inand with the private sector is
that what gave rise to the ewg
verification program that have exactly
it um and is that I know that's a
rigorous sort of standard that you set
and companies can you know sort of go
through that process and if they
successfully come out the other side you
enumerate them in this list is that also
something that can be put on a label on
the product yep um okay I didn't that's
actually something I didn't know and
then that's a my broader question is
around label labeling in general and how
you know that gets weaponized as well
totally through these greenwashing C
to meaning and now you can Pi a and
there's so many labels on it I don't
know one of these I should be paying
attention to if any of them and so
because there's so many even if your
label is is on a product amongst those
other ones it has a a diluting effect on
it you know because like what are we
supposed to actually pay attention to
well I mean here's how I look at them
because I you know I know it's in our
standard what's behind ew G verified um
and I compare the way we make that known
to people to the way others do and some
of them are pretty simple you know no
animal testing the paa label is pretty
straightforward but some of the other
ones are are trickier uh what I do is I
I look to see uh have they spelled out
in great detail what the standard means
and we do that we publish it we've been
you know when we put it out there it can
be copied then or you know cherry
pricked a little bit but we didn't think
there was any other way than to have 40
pages of detail about our standard
secondly um we have staff scientists
doing the work this is not a marketing
program like some of these
certifications are we have staff
scientists who are digging into you know
tough questions a lot of these
ingredients because they're not
regulated when you're not regulated you
don't have a battery of studies in some
government agency that anyone can look
at it's sometimes there's no data at all
or maybe there will be a an independent
study or an academic somewhere who's
studied this chemical as it's inhaled by
workers but hasn't studied it as it
occurs in a skin care product right well
what do you do well we try and figure
out the toxicology and the exposure as
best we can in great
detail takes a lot of time takes a lot
of effort and that's what companies who
come into the process some of whom
halfway in wonder why they started but
it's very it's very tough to get our
Mark um you don't get to write a check
and get it by any means but but I think
that's the trick we're in a kind of a a
wild west now with certifications just
like the the market we're trying to
correct right there's all these
certifiers out there all these standards
out there some of them I look at and I
don't think they're very robust I look
at the organizations I don't see a staff
of scientists are not publishing in the
peer-reviewed liter
they're not they don't have phds or
master's degrees in uh a relevant
discipline and um it it worries me that
that those are out there I can't do much
about it except to make our standard you
know more rigorous and talk more
companies into trying to take a crack at
it other than ewg verification is there
are there labels out there I'm just
thinking of the consumer like what so if
somebody's listening to this and they're
going to the supermarket later today
which lab labels are
meaningful I think the organic label is
Meaningful um once you understand what
the standard does and doesn't do um I'll
give you the example of pesticides when
we've tested and others have tested
produce for pesticides when organic
produce is tested it's very rare to find
any toxic chemical on it um so I trust
that standard with respect to pesticides
or questions about some of the animal
welfare issues that we have too we've
been supporting efforts to strength and
Animal Welfare standards nothing in
there about energy nothing in there
about Labor nothing in there about
packaging um it's just how the food is
literally grown and even there there are
some areas that people take issue with
but I I I bring organic food home to my
family to my son and my my wife and my
wife does the same the the um I think
the uh the ewg standard is robust I
think some of the retail-based standards
are a little uh less less rigorous by
some of the chains I don't want to name
any of them but um some of the companies
that have announced that they're going
to have sustainability standards it's
sometimes pretty hard in my view and in
our staff's view to trace exactly what
they mean by sustainability how
rigorously they review them and so forth
um so uh I I wish I could I don't feel
comfortable going down the list but I
get it and it's hard it's hard because
on the one hand you could have a
certification that is good and rigorous
but it doesn't account for all these
other things that are also important
correct all of the distribution of this
product and how the workers were treat
you know this is like and the the onus
being on the consumer to figure that out
for themselves is is insane like we need
order to this process well I mean uh
I'll give you a good example some years
ago there was there was a lot of uh
emphasis on uh making sure that organic
Growers had union labor and that they
obeyed would abide by uh laws affecting
immigrant labor and we certainly agreed
with that but our position was well we
need the bigger
fix so that the whole food system is
playing by rules that make sense we
should we shouldn't have a peace meal
you know yeah we shouldn't be letting
them cut corners and we shouldn't
expect huge problems like that to just
be solved by one still reasonably small
segment of the food industry so it in my
view that's where you have to step back
and say hey we we cannot step away from
the policy process we need to fix our
immigration laws we need to fix minimum
wage we need to fix all of these things
as a society we don't work on all of
those at ewg some issues cry out you
know public health issues like gun
violence as a public health Advocate it
hits me pretty hard when I read about
these outrageous incidents of gun
violence but we don't work on that but
but we that needs to be worked on at the
societal level and I feel the same way
about uh all aspects of pollution
control food safety and so forth we just
have to not
let ourselves think that we can chop our
way out of these problems there's some
of them that are too big and too rooted
um and and we don't want to just Retreat
behind our our walls uh whether it's
middle class or above can be tempting to
do U we all we all know that Temptation
and not look at the rest of the world
and how it's fairing but the rest of the
world it turns out does catch up uh it's
the world we live in we haven't found
another planet yet and until we do we
need air pollution control that protects
uh you know people who are near
refineries and near highways we need
protection for Farm Workers we need more
organic or safer pesticides to protect
them in the fields all of these
things don't tend to get embraced in
individual product standards or at least
at the at the scale that we need to
protect all those people right
right nobody's diet is absolutely
perfectly dialed every single sing day
without fail which is why I believe in
smart sound science back supplementation
and my go-to source for all my
supplement needs is momentous because
everything they make is sourced from the
highest quality ingredients and
rigorously tested by Third parties to
ensure optimal efficacy you want to do a
little showand tell let me show you some
of my favorites my Shrine to All Things
momentous here this is the Sleep stack
these are the Sleep packs that you can
take when you're traveling and then this
is my daily lineup of things that I take
pretty much every day Rain Drive pre-
podcast pre-writing
session for cognitive
Health tongat Ali testosterone
booster basically a whole lineup
turmeric every day four of
these listen there's a lot of BS in the
supplement World which is why I trust
momentus is industry-leading quality
standards here's what you're going to do
you're going to try momentus for
yourself by immediately right in this
moment going to Liv mous.com
rroll or click the link in the
description below where you will be
rewarded with a full 20% off all their
top-of-the-line
products with the increasing edification
and awareness of of consumers all across
the world um Comes This broadening
awareness of just how toxic our planet
is from the glyphosate that is in our
breakfast cereal to the posos forever
chemical that is found in our drinking
water to a shocking extent yeah um that
can in turn lead to a sense of Despair
or or paralysis like this problem is too
big there's chemicals uh of varying
degrees of tox
in everything I put on my body and
everything I put in you know in my body
uh what is somebody to do and you know
I'm thinking about have you read Darren
O's book fatal
conveniences of course he canvases all
of this he has Solutions and and
strategies for how to you know make
better choices and live better within
that but it's it is you know despairing
toally to read this and realize that
there is almost no product that we
purchase that has any contact with our
body that we shouldn't have a Graver
concern about yeah you you you need to
be aware and um sometimes the awareness
itself is too heavy a lift and so people
tune out I get that um sometimes people
who have been in the field a long time
uh kind of burn out because they feel
like well look we're we're just not
getting the progress we need in
Washington or maybe Sacramento um and um
so I'm just going to you know do my very
best in my personal life and my circle
of friends friends my family um I get
that that's you know I I'm not I'm not
so far off from those feelings um I I
went on a vacation earlier this year to
Hawaii and we had just done a study
where our scientists read through the
the literature for evidence of these
past chemicals per and poly floral alkal
substances these are the Teflon
chemicals the Scotch Guard chemicals the
brand names that are uh created in such
a way that they never break down the
forever chemicals you the term you used
and we had just surveyed uh past
chemicals in Wildlife around the world
looked at over 330
species and found it in all of them and
so I'm on vacation in Hawaii and I'm you
know I'm taking a break from work I'm
I'm there with my son but Hawaii is the
front lines of this battlefield right
exactly I don't mean to like no your
story exactly so so you know the first
the first afternoon we go whale watching
I'm thinking well okay yeah we found
past and all those species of whales and
I'm looking at the the birds flying
around as we bird watch uh from our
condo and yeah just yeah and then I'm
looking at the fish on my plate that's
caught fresh and the waterers off the
coast of Hawaii and there's this our our
footprint is everywhere the human
footprint is ubiquitous on this planet
even in places where no human foot has
ever been right and so here's here's my
take on it first of
all there are definitely things you can
you can do personally to
dramatically Reduce by thousands and
thousands of exposure events every year
your personal exposure your family's
exposure your friends if they'll listen
to you exposure to these chemicals you
have agency to do that the second thing
is that agency if it's applied on a wide
enough basis does start sending signals
to Sea Sues and marketers and others and
they start reformulating um sometimes
they do it reluctantly there and there
are big fights uh sometimes they resist
it uh but but that force is being
exerted out there and in many cases it's
being felt the example I always give
rooftop solar the utilities are freaked
out about the only competition they've
ever had for the past 100 years which is
their former customers putting panels on
their roof and now putting batteries
there and they're fighting against it
we're involved in fights all over the
country certainly in California and and
North Carolina so that is being felt the
final thing is and this is the this is
the toughest thing in a way that if you
if you stay out of the fight you're much
more much more likely to give up I think
than if you get in it a little bit so
put a little skin in the game pick an
issue pick a an organization pick
someone whose story you've heard maybe
it's something you've heard here about
pasas uh and the work ewg is doing maybe
it's something an animal welfare group
is doing I don't care what it might be
put a little skin in the game uh you
know make a commitment that you're going
to flex some Civic muscles right
you're going to I don't know what Iron
Man is for for civil society maybe we
should maybe we should invent that where
you turning it into your own endurance
event your own Des you train a little
bit for it right you you you have some
failures you get some injuries uh you
fall short but if we step back and give
up our societal engagement our Civic
engagement then then nothing will ever
change and even though it's overwhelming
even though we have screwed some many
things up whether it's endangered
species or plastic in the oceans or
pasas in all of us it's in newborn
babies we find pasas in in babies and
lots of other chemicals when they come
into the world and not just here all
over the world and what is the posos the
forever chemicals do to the body well
the weird thing about this class of
chemicals is that as they've been
studied we found more Health end points
there it's linked to certain cancers uh
it disrupts our hor hormone system uh it
can affect uh the efficacy of uh
vaccines and other medicines uh it can
cause uh other forms of uh of damage
birth
defects it's it's unusual for a a
chemical to have that many Health end
points and we we know that they're there
because of studies that were done of the
community that we first studied um in
West Virginia around the Teflon plant
that Pont ran for years and there was a
class action suit and the brilliant
lawyer Rob bot uh who's been a dear
friend for 20 plus years he decided uh
to go to the to the class and say look
we've got a settlement offer but instead
of taking the settlement offer in cash
how about we do this how about we do a
study and we impanel three scientists to
look at all the evidence we collect
evidence we collect blood from all these
people and let's find out if there are
links to any diseases and to their
credit these folks in West Virginia said
let's yeah let's get to the truth well
there's your Civic action there that's
there's your commitment to the long game
instead of taking the that's like that's
some Aaron Brockovich exactly
exactly and and and Aaron's been a a
close Ally for decades too and she works
in the same way and so that study
showed problems with cancer problems
with the endocrine system uh
hypertension all kinds of things that
only came about because thousands and
thousands of people gave their blood
measured the past levels and then they
gave detailed medical records that
allowed the the epidemiologist to say
Hey you know there's a relationship here
wow wow that's powerful biggest study
ever in the world of uh a toxic chemical
on human health wow um your critics
accuse you of fear-mongering yeah uh
these chemicals are in such minute doses
uh that you know it's hardly something
to be concerned about so I want to give
you an opportunity to respond to that
but just to contextualize it the way
that I reframed how I think about this
is is courtesy of Darren who who said
sure but think about what you do every
single day from the moment you get up
until your head hits the pillow how many
products your body comes into contact
with from drinking out of the tap to the
toothpaste to the cereal to the you know
the the the plastic container that
contains whatever beverage you know it's
like you're just you're just impaled by
inputs you know hundreds of times a day
so your body is slowly accumulating
micro doses of all of these things and
each in each each you know in isolation
perhaps your body could metabolize them
and process them without harm except for
the forever chemicals they're forever
chemicals because they accumulate and
never go away um but at some point your
body reaches a threshold where the
inputs become uh too much for the body
to do anything about and that's where
you start to enter the world of harm so
how do you think about that what is your
what is your response to that criticism
yeah no it it I you know we we feel it's
really important to face that criticism
headon because of what we just finished
discussing which is people getting
paralyzed so what would be it would be a
very easy response for people to say
look you know this is I I'm I feel
healthy now we're living into our 70s uh
you know I'm I'm doing fine maybe these
doses are to Windex and Clorox my entire
life of course you know a certain fairly
large percentage of people who are heavy
smokers don't get lung cancer either so
um you know it's it's interesting um we
usually roll out a couple of arguments
let me let me go to the the one that you
so eloquently described this incredible
mixture of chemicals that we know is in
us because we've measured it in people's
blood it's not like a a model that we've
extrapolated you know we've done blood
testing at ewg sent it to labs and found
hundreds of chemicals in newborn babies
and and we know that adults have have
even more so the first thing to say is
if you ask industry what that means they
will say
nothing we regulate chemicals one at a
time if I want to put a pesticide on the
market I don't care what's already in
your body what's already on the market
what else you might be exposed to if
that pesticide and if it's an
insecticide it kills insects through
their nervous system it doesn't give the
insects cancer it you know it it kills
them right away so what other neurotoxic
do you have are you exposed to are you
exposed to lead paint in an old home or
are you exposed to do you have Trace
levels of pcbs in your blood from where
you used to live all of these things
industry's official view is it's too
complex to study um there's we don't
have evidence that these specific
combinations because we can never
really you know uh we can never there's
too many variables model them yeah and
so um let's just put that aside well
real scientists don't put that aside
what real scientists say is that looks
bad we ought to be doing something about
that so the first the first thing I
remind people of is we we don't really
look at the real world the stew of
chemicals you have in you the second
thing I remind people of
is have you have you heard recently
about a chemical getting banned and most
people have pesticides from time to time
are banned there's a whole list of them
that EPA has banned over the years and
in every single
case
EPA the pesticide industry and the
companies that made uh the products that
had the pesticides in them in every
single case they said it was safe right
up until the time it was
banned and then it's not safe well it
was never safe the science didn't catch
up the industry pushed back against The
Regulators we know that there are
chemicals in our bodies now that
Regulators haven't gotten to and we know
they're of concern when will they get to
them and maybe you don't want to wait so
I might be accused of fearmongering but
I would say look there's several
chemicals glyphosate is one of them I
happen to think you should probably not
have in your body um I think you should
take steps to avoid it don't eat
oat-based products that are conventional
if they have glyphosate in them eat
organic and you eliminate almost all the
dietary exposure right there why not do
it and and recognize that EPA might
change their mind on glyphosate at any
time and when they do unless you've been
eating organic you've been following
epa's advice and you've been exposed to
a lot of chemicals and then the final
the final thing I I mention is look
don't don't take my word for it look at
the scientific professions and see what
they say what does the neurological
Society of America say at this point the
the president of it um has has come out
gave her um presidential
presentation uh a year ago at their
convention and it was on environmental
chemicals and the impact they might be
having on our nervous system look at the
endocrine Society that's uh that's
20,000 or so clinicians scientists
researchers and so forth it's who you go
to if you think you have a a you know
some sort of hormone
mediated health problem that's who you
see you see an
endocrinologist the statements on their
website about
endocrine active chemicals synthetic
chemicals that are acting in our body
and fooling our body into thinking that
they are hormones and they're not and
they're causing all kinds of problems
they have a a major platform and they
work with us all the time to try and
strengthen protection against these
chemicals that the industry officially
until recently said it's not a it's not
even a thing the scientists who study it
say it's a thing but the industries who
make it say it's not I trust the
scientists who are concerned about our
health same with the Academy of
Pediatrics you know American Lung
Association all these professional
associations have reached conclusions
about environmental chemicals that
basically comes down to this we're not
doing the job we need to do to regulate
these chemicals as you said earlier Rich
before they come on to the market and
once we're exposed to them we're exposed
to them in combination with many other
chemicals you probably as as clean as I
know you eat and live if we did a blood
draw we I know we'd find pasas in your
body now right because it's probably
been there the halflife is maybe for
most of them about four or five years if
you get a fresh dose four or five years
before you get rid of half of that then
you would have pcbs that are left over
from decad ago when Monsanto put them in
electrical Transformers to insulate
you'd have some still have some DDT in
your body uh even though you've eaten
organic probably for I don't know decad
when was DDT banned DDT was banned in
1970 yeah and but it's still in the soil
and some places they still grow in those
places so the the point really is look
if if there are smart ways you can in
your personal life avoid these exposures
and and that's what ewg tries to do
personal care
food you're we go through every room in
your house mattresses
everything we basically say look if you
if you are concerned about this and we
think there's reason to be concerned
here are some options you can follow in
your everyday life sometimes the options
aren't great because it has to be done
by law and regulation but there are many
where you can uh clean up and so why not
do that and and why is industry pushing
back so hard against every single
regulation we're finally about to start
regulating and then I'll I'll I'll open
up to to your next question these past
chemicals are in water all over the
country we did a a peer reviewed paper
that estimated at least 200 million
Americans have past chemicals in their
drink finish drinking water right out of
the tap that um at at a level that we
consider is unsafe what we and we think
one part per trillion is the most you
should have not billion per trillion
right EPA has come out now with a
proposal that's very close to where we
are they're saying for a group of these
compounds the legal limit that would
require action by the water supplier
should be four parts per trillion so
this is a really important scientific
threshold and Regulatory threshold that
industry is fighting back against very
hard because if that level is set there
that means the science underneath it is
accepted by the agency and it is they
believe it's that dangerous it should be
basically gone from the water
altogether industry is fighting back
very hard because what that says is that
all along this stuff has been much more
dangerous than industry L on yeah yeah I
read your uh water and pfa's report and
it's it's quite shocking uh the extent
to which this crisis is much larger than
one might imagine 26 million people in
hundreds of communities have toxic
forever chemicals these posos molecules
in drinking water you guys estimate
there could be nearly 30,000 industrial
polluters releasing posos into the
environment including into sources of
drinking water yeah and and you know
who's gotten hammered the worst uh and
and these are the people who we should
uh be honoring not uh
not dissing with this kind of behavior
is uh First Responders
firefighters um they're getting the
maximum they're getting hammered because
this past stuff is in their ready gear
and for many of them they go through
exercises where you're putting out a a
Liquid Fire a fuel fire well what for
years people sprayed on it and still do
is chemicals that have pasas in them
fire retardant that have pasas in it
that helps put out the fire the pasas
ends up in the water water due to uh the
discharge of industrial pollutants
that's not properly contained stored and
and sort of disposed of it's all kinds
of sources it's these abandoned sites
that had Pas dumped in them that
happened in West Virginia um it's the
it's the air bases that our military are
near uh where they've done drills and
our service members are drinking the
toxic water with their families when
they're stationed at those bases um
uh manufacturers like Wolverine that
dumped their
excess um you know waterproofing
materials in a way that polluted
drinking water all over Michigan on and
on um it was carelessness it was a lack
of Regulation and oversight it was a
moral failing I think on the part of the
companies time and again uh we only
really find out the truth of these
things not through a regulatory process
which is should be the way it works but
through litig ation some trial lawyer
takes a company to court and they win a
discovery fight they get documents from
those companies that the companies never
wanted to see the light of day those
documents come out and we see as we saw
in the case of you know Dupont and its
Teflon chemical 3M and its Scotch Guard
chemical we see it in the case of fuel
additives like mtbe on and on we saw it
with tobacco the companies knew the
companies knew their own scientists knew
that these chemicals were harmful and at
some point when the executives were
confronted with the decision are we
going to stop making it or make it
differently shift to something
else the decision was made no there's
just too Goddamn much money to be made
let's keep doing it until until we can't
but if there was ever a bipartisan issue
it's clean drinking water not right and
and and can't we construct um you know
Criminal penalties that are so punitive
that it would that it would insulate
against any any kind of wayward decision
on behalf of a you know industry or a
corporation to cut corners and poll in
this way I I think criminal penalties
are totally appropriate it's been
attempted for example uh the the uh
George Bush the second Bush his justice
department tried to take asbest
Executives to court uh and and
difficulty prevailing um but I think it
should be uh there should be a a
criminal uh element to these Executives
who see these questions in front of them
this evidence in front of them and don't
do anything about it but what ends up
happening is once they see the evidence
they try and hide it even longer uh and
they try and push back I mean if you if
you look at the testimony from for
example 3M uh their internal documents
show all kinds of health problems with
their chemical that was used in
scotchguard their public statements are
there's no evidence of human harm M so
yeah I think that absolutely should be
the case and I think we should make sure
that when this information comes out
that Regulators pay attention to it it
helped make the case for these past
chemicals the fact that finally the
information came out the and the way it
came out was not because the companies
submitted it to EPA but because this
lawyer Rob bot West Virginia he won the
cases in the Civil actions he took in in
uh West Virginia and then he he sent the
documents to EPA that Dupont and 3M
should have sent decades earlier wow uh
in terms of winning cases uh I want to
come back to agriculture for a minute um
the most pervasive prolific pesticide on
the planet is Roundup the active
ingredient in Roundup is glyphosate and
there has been quite a bit of litigation
with successful results to
establish the harm that this chemical
can produce and yet it persists yeah so
what is it what does the landscape look
like in terms of eradicating this
ingredient in
pesticides um and why is this such a
difficult Hill to climb particularly
given that it has become because of
consumer interest uh something that
people are aware of in a way that maybe
10 years ago only a few people knew
about but a lot of people are aware of
glyphosate and its potential harm no
well I I have a colleague Carrie Gillum
a journalist uh who uh manages the new
lead our journalism program at ewg she's
written a couple of books on this um one
of the other common things about
glyphosate and the chemicals we just
discussed is a a very clear corporate
record that they knew there were
problems and they worked assiduously to
cover them up
uh they tried to criticize scientists
that were doing independent research
showing problems with glyphosate when
their own studies turned out uh to have
uh surfaced health problems they rewrote
them and doctored them and so forth B
big big Scandal there in my view the the
situation now is is sort of like this uh
most of the Roundup is sprayed on crops
that have been genetically engineered to
resist its uh
uh plant killing properties and the
benefit to a farmer
is years ago you'd have to go out and
plow a field and plow under the weeds or
you'd have to time your weed killer
application to before the crop came up
well once they were genetically
engineered to resist this one chemical
called glyphosate that's trade name is
Roundup in the can then you could go out
and you could plant your Fields And if
the crops were coming up and you had a
big operation and you didn't get to it
right away you could go and spray that
field and it would kill the weeds but
the corn and the soybeans and the cotton
was fine so this was a boon for farmers
and that's why it's used so widely but
also along with that um with with the
genetic
modifications that eliminates any
concern about using this pesticide
sparingly exactly so these Foods that's
the thing with GMOs it's not the
modification of the food itself as much
as it as it is the resistance to the
pesticide which means those foods are
going to be much more Rife with you know
uh greater amounts of these chemicals in
them than the organic version and and
people are exposed especially in rural
areas where this is sprayed in the
springtime it's in the air it's in the
rainwater uh there's I think evidence
that's pretty compelling to me from the
NIH that uh these these populations have
elevated risk of of certain cancers very
similar to the the grounds keeper ERS
that have won some of the cases these
tended to be um homeowners or someone
who is a professional U groundskeeper um
who sprayed at a round up from a
backpack sprayer and they did it
routinely and they were exposed to a lot
of it maybe they probably didn't wear
enough protective gear or maybe it's
spilled on them or just from the the
amount they used it in an orchard or
around their their Farmstead or wherever
it might be around a school uh those
folks had an elev exposure even compared
to a lot of farmers and that elevated
exposure we could deal with that if we
you could keep gate on the market but
you would have to dramatically change
the formulation of it and you'd have to
make sure that uh people use protective
gear and so forth that's high risk for
the farm population we can't use it at
the scale we're using it and not expose
Farm families and Rural communities and
then the final exposure right is Route
is in food which is in a in a fashion
that we've done a lot of work on that
you might not
expect but it has to do with how the
pesticide is used um you said it just
right this is this is in a way sort of
like the Oxycontin of of of
pesticides once you get a big market for
it something that you thought was for
acute application Acute Care Hospice
care for oxycotton right small Market $3
$40 million but suddenly they're
prescribing so widely it's a billion
Doll Market well it's a ver it's
vertically integrated with the seed so
you create an entire Marketplace
absolutely the whole system works so
what they did was um eventually they
said well what are some of the other
applications we could have and this is
where the food exposure happens when
they spray corn and soybeans and cotton
it's early in the season and for the
most part the seed has not even formed
so you don't see high levels of
glyphosate in those in corn cotton and
soybeans where you see it um and we've
found it in our tests is in oats and the
reason you see it is
because they spray the oats because they
haven't been genetically engineered to
resist it they spray it at the end of
the season to kind of dry out the crop
while the seed head is fully ripe ready
to ready for almost ready for Harvest
makes it much easier makes it uniform
for the farmers to go through the field
and and harvest the oats in Canada where
we get most of our oats and so our
studies showed that uh dietary exposure
is largely confined not entirely but
largely confined to Oat Bas cereals
chickpeas a few other types of of grains
where it is
sprayed with epa's blessing in the case
of uh the imported oats and and
chickpeas here and other things with
epa's blessing uh towards the end of the
season and it's literally in the food
shouldn't be we should eliminate that
use right away we have a petition with a
bunch of food companies before EPA now
to requesting that the
agency disallow these end of season uses
for the rest of it it's a you know the
litigation is playing out for these uh
for the people who have been exposed I
think more and more farmers are going to
come in and start suing too and here's
the Dilemma here's
the what Monsanto or Bayer basically
says is if the cost is too high we'll go
bankrupt we won't be able to pay anyone
a settlement and so we have to be able
to keep making and selling
glyphosate in order to make the money we
need to make to pay the people that
we've agreed to settle because they've
been harmed by glyphosate okay that's
its own that's that's like some kind of
uh Kurt vaget novel narrative and and
you see it time and again uh with with
these kinds of chemical uh situations
chemical exposure situations where the
the companies basically plead well we
you know let us keep making it and and
maybe we'll try and do something about
the harm so-called injunctive relief
we'll make changes in the label or how
we formulate it uh but we have to keep
making it because that's how we make
enough money to pay the claims it's
heartbreaking right yeah that that that
would be enough to
to disenchant me from your field of work
well very despairing you know yeah it
is there are plenty of reasons to think
that we can uh significantly reduce
glyphosate exposure for most for a big
part of the population that gets it
through food and then um you know EPA
just has to take a stronger stand on its
field use and its use in um
residentially um we you know we we think
that um all of this stuff should be
taken out of the Home Depots and the
targets and other parts of of the
economy uh it shouldn't be allowed now
there are more dangerous weed killers
out there I have to say if you look at
it just from a toxicological standpoint
there are some very worrisome uh weed
killers that would probably take their
place so there you have that that kind
of
whack-a-mole uh phenomena that's been
long at work I mean think about the
whole system we got rid of DDT and we
brought on Organo phosphate insecticides
the they they killed a lot of people now
we've moved from the Organo phosphate to
the
neonicotinoids and we're very worried
about the impact they may be having on
wildlife and human health so but it's
the enemy you know for right now the
enemy you know yeah and you know
obviously these things live on a
spectrum of harm on the Red Alert side
with respect to glyphosate the
actionable takeaway or the immediate
takeaway for somebody who's listening to
this is to pay greater attention to the
oats that they purchase and consume you
know and that's a real easy immediate
fix like anything that you purchase that
has oats in it pay attention to the
label and that would be a reason to go
organic on that and that alone and and
we exactly and we've also seen some
evidence that some of the
suppliers and some of the buyers of
conventional oats the like cereal
companies um they've announced that they
don't want to have glyphosate in their
system anymore even if it's
conventionally grown right that's
positive um some of the testing we've
done suggests that the levels are going
down in conventional oats this is all
consumers government did didn't lift a
finger government's on the side of
Monsanto and Bay are saying no problem
but consumers are saying you know what
what I
just call me crazy but I just I just
don't want that little bit of weed
killer in my breakfast how much of the
oat Harvest is um funneled to uh
livestock feed is that part of it or is
that mostly soybean I I think um there
is some feeding of Oats to livestock but
not that that's not the primary feed um
depending on the animal right so if it's
cattle it's it's uh it's it's corn and a
mixture of other uh other field crops um
oats is not a it's too expensive to feed
to animals unless it's um an emergency
situation or leftover or something so
it's it's mostly the oats grown for for
food use and um Canadian Farmers got the
go-ahead from their government to spray
round up at the end of the season we
don't have many many acres of Oats left
in this country it's all gone to Corn
soybeans interesting um why is it that
that the EU is so much better at this
than the USA when you look at the
European Union um they're way ahead of
the curve they're not perfect but in
terms of the number of chemicals that
they have banned in consumer products uh
it's it it make it it casts an
embarrassing shade on where we're at
yeah it's not you're right it's not
perfect I mean there thousands that
they've banned right yeah in personal
care products they're looks like they're
they're starting looks like they're
trying to take a tougher Str stand on p
with glyphosate I think they I think the
jury's still out but it looks like they
might approve with restrictions uh use
of glyphosate in the EU I thought that
are there certain countries within the
EU that have already banned it though
right yeah but the EU wide I think
that're they leave it to the comp
countries to make their decisions but
why is it better you know it's um it's
such a good question uh I I think each
culture in each of those countries gives
you some indication as to why they feel
that basically this modern technology is
not to be trusted and and as a
consequence
they they are willing to say look the
the facts may not all be in we may still
have some legitimate open scientific
questions but the weight of evidence
tells us that we should act with
precaution that we should probably not
allow these
chemicals in proximity to people whether
it's in food or uh in uh air pollution
or what have you now there are areas
where the US is has taken a stronger
line and in a way the EU caught up to us
on environmental law regulation from the
from the pace we we took in the 70s
which was amazing um but it has slowed
down and I think now what you're seeing
in Europe is a sense that um
these these chemical
economies are not the rigid
inflexible thumbs up or thumbs down uh
kinds of propositions that they're made
out to be in the US like well we when
when pcbs were discovered to be in
wildlife and people all over the world
and uh this is in the late early
1970s Monsanto said well we we can't get
rid of PCB we won't have an electrical
grid just we'll just we won't have
electricity anymore DDT the same thing
we'll starve we won't be able to have
food et Etc and over over time we see
that there's a resilience when you send
a strong regulatory signal hey figure
out another way to do it and at the
human level I've talked to I don't know
how many people in in Industry often not
on the record who are more in the
engineering end of the Continuum not the
business end these are the problems
solvers for these companies and they say
in
effect why didn't you tell me you wanted
safe I'm an engineer give me the spec
you said you want it cheap you wanted a
lot you wanted it to have these
criteria if you wanted it safe tell me
what the safe spec is I'll try and hit
it but um but I think in in in Europe
what you see is a sense maybe a a you
know because they've been at this game
longer they've been producing food
longer they've had Eon that was the
center of the Industrial Revolution I
think there's a sense of you know
workers jobs are at stake that could be
a factor if we ban something if we
change the supply chain if we go to
electric vehicles these all these
questions are there for them but I think
they have a sense a his a longer
historical Arc about resilience than we
have in this country we still think the
new thing is is what's been in front of
us for not very long and we dare not
deviate from it because we don't know
what's beyond that but in fact most of
these pesticides you used in agriculture
have been around since Sputnik you know
it's old technology we're just hanging
on to it in Europe I think there's a
willingness to say uh we need to invent
our way out of this life's life's too
important and so we're going to we're
going to
regulate with the evidence we have even
though industry complains it's not
enough we haven't looked at this haven't
looked at that I think in Europe there's
a much more open attitude toward airing
on the side of precaution so it's more
of a perspective than it is a particular
model of checks and balances or a way of
navigating through this problem it's
about values not some system that we
could look at that they have that we
could model here well law by law what
you see is their culture expressed in
law in many cases right so it it's it
it's sort of what you're what the point
you're making you you really have to
look at each specific thing they're
doing how they're regulating past how
they're looking at glyphosate how
they're looking at cell phone radiation
in all of those cases the common
difference is often uh a a posture of
precaution that we don't have here we we
think that chemicals and Technologies
are innocent until proven guilty in
Europe it's more of a okay you invented
something cool it does this thing for
your company and for the economy and
consumers like it that that doesn't mean
we shouldn't take a closer look sure I I
I have to believe that part of that must
be their their connection with the long
tale of History you know the
uninterrupted you know you know
generation after generation uh uh you
know contact with the Earth and because
we're a newer country built upon
Innovation and progress and forward
momentum we have less of that you know
as part of our value set yeah I mean
look at the GMO labeling debate right we
were involved at that in the US here we
you know we uh we have a really weak
labeling system here and I always used
to get in debates with these industry
food industry people who were saying
well you know the cost of food is going
to go way up I mean we just if we have
to put those labels and people start
changing their behavior so my my first
thought was am I really
hearing a food industry executive
worried about food prices going up too
high but my second thought
was what could we possibly learn from
France and Italy about food they seem to
have labeling there and I whenever I go
I seem to be pretty darn happy with the
quality and quantity of the food um
especially the quality of it the whole
notion that it would be a camel's nose
under the tent against technology to
tell people on a label that it's
genetically modified whether you're
worried about it or not I I'm I'm I come
down where you do I I haven't seen the
evidence yet that the actual genetic
modification is dangerous although I
don't trust Monsanto to tell us if they
did have evidence but I am worried about
the pesticides that go with G many GMO
foods but to why wouldn't you tell
people who want to know that about their
food give that to them in a
straightforward way on the label and
Industry spent tens of millions of
dollars uh any any resistance to
transparency is going to evoke suspicion
and the food industry is is if it's
known for anything it's known for its
Devotion to a lack of transparency yeah
no exactly right and I think this is the
thing that the internet has introduced
into our lives it's what has made ewg
the fact that people could go online and
consult lots of different sources I mean
we we have people coming to us who have
read the same academic papers we have
now they may not be toxicologists or
chemists but they've gotten the gist of
it that um in in the abstract or maybe
in the article itself that there's a
concern with these pfast chemicals and
that level of awareness and information
could only be possible if it was coming
to you right in your home on your laptop
or your phone or your iPad because you
know these aren't people who are going
to go back to school and brush up on
biology and chemistry and toxicology
it's just the the transparency that's
permitted through the exchange of
information online and misinformation
fair to say has has changed everything
and that has you know industry running
Running Scared as you mentioned earlier
every five years the farm bill comes up
for a vote uh that vote is end of this
month right end of September I think
they'll make it I think they'll have to
push it off yeah uh and with this you
know contentious uh piece of
legislation um are a number of of of
agricultural
subsidies um and other kind of add-ons
and Tagalongs um that are worthy of
exploration and discussion so I'm
interested first maybe you know explain
what these a subsidies are what is you
know Up For Debate right now what we
should be concerned about and just the
system at L and how these subsidies
contribute to uh you know further
entrenching A system that is leading us
astray yeah well the subsidies have been
around 90 years uh they started during
the New Deal and it was a basically uh
an emergency response to the conditions
of destitution and uh extreme poverty in
farm country that actually grabbed Farm
country a full decade before the
Depression hit the rest of the economy
yeah it's it's to ensure it was it was
born out of a desire to create stability
amidst the farm industry and to ensure
an adequate supply of food to fend off
starvation and hunger like it's it comes
from a very good place but it has
metastasized into something Al together
different that's right from those from
those uh laudable uh Beginnings um now
we have a system that basically spends
tens of billions of dollars
and sends your dollars taxpayers dollars
and sends them to an increasingly narrow
group of farmers who grow a handful of
crops uh corn uh soybeans wheat cotton
rice those are the big subsidized crops
because they're the larger acreage I
mean we we have a fairly small acreage
relative to those of fruits and
vegetables in the US and we import
fruits and vegetables on top of that but
you know the the corn acreage is you
know it's not quite the size of
California you know 90 plus million
Acres probably California is over a 100
so you're talking about lots of acreage
and hundreds of thousands of producers
and over time from over those 90 years
uh the subsidy system has been embedded
in land values it now uh helps prop up
input prices knowing that you're going
to get a check every year based on the
amount produce the more you produce the
more money you get from the government
is Central to business planning every
year on thousands of farms across the
Heartland and what this means is that
huge amounts of money are going to a
fairly small number of people we we
publish the names of all the recipients
on the ewg website and the amount they
receive and we published it since uh we
go back to
1995 and since
1995 we have sent almost half a trillion
dollars to those
Farmers right and 70% of the money goes
to 10% of the recipients about 20% of
the money goes to 1% so it's it's quite
a pyramid it's concentrated because the
large farmers get more
money in effect taxpayers are helping
them keep their businesses alive and
growing so they can buy out their
neighbors so we're we're in effect party
to this process of consolidation in
agriculture so that's that's one issue
and the farm bill every 5 years sort of
modifies the rules under which those
subsidies are distributed I should
mention a couple of other things it also
establishes this the food stamp program
formerly known as uh food stamps it's
now called Snap supplemental uh
nutrition assistance program that's a
the bigger price tag but it uh it
benefits many more people right um it's
about uh it's a big part of the farm
bill and then there's all these
environmental and conservation measures
that are reauthorized that we fight over
in the farm bill and then rural
development so forth but the big ticket
items are snap the food
stamps commodity subsidies and crop
insurance and and conservation so this
Farm Bill fight that's coming along now
like the previous ones um they have to
renew these programs every years or they
get in trouble sometimes you're right
they don't they don't make their
deadlines so they'll extend them for a
period of time but they really have to
go back and rewrite the law because the
underlying law will
expire and so what the public interest
Community has been doing really since
the the 70s and
80s is has been coming forward and and
being part of the horse trading so you
have advocates for nutrition assistance
to low-income people going in there and
saying saying okay if you're going to
give this much money to farm subsidies
you've got to help out urban populations
with the snap program and Rural
populations low-income people
everywhere the environmental Community
starting in the mid 80s and I was part
of this generation it's kind of how I
cut my teeth as an environmental
lobbyist we came in and said hey all
this money that's being spent on
agriculture it's just it it's plowing up
lands causing erosion more pesticide use
damage to Wildlife Wetlands water
quality we need to have conservation
benefits attached to these uh programs
and we need to have money to help
farmers at least correct some of the
damage so that
that in legislative terms it it it's
like a mosh pit where all these
interests come together and uh and horse
trade to get um every five years of farm
bill passed and so this year um we're
pushing again to hang on to a
substantial amount of money that was
added in the inflation reduction act
that would invest a lot in climate smart
farming so that's our number one
priority something like 1718 billion
dollars would go out to Farmers but it
would help them manage nitrogen on their
lands help them with cover crops help
them do all kinds of things that they
should be doing anyway we don't regulate
them to do it so our bargain is we'll
we'll share part of the cost of it at
least that's the position in the
conservation Community if you want to
save your Wetlands we'll give you some
money to set that aside we're not
insisting that uh we we regulate you
from from making productive use of it um
if it's if it's legal and so this Farm
Bill process now is adding some very
exciting potentially uh new elements and
one of them is a lot of us are making
the case that it's time to invest
in more fresh fruits and veget
vegetables for kids let's move in the
direction of supporting that let's
improve the quality of nutrition
assistance if we can we want to maintain
the benefit make it better like we did
during covid we would also like to see
USDA putting their muscle behind
plant-based Foods we have spent tens of
billions of dollars to prop up through
crop subsidies that grow the grain that
the cattle eat and the chickens eat and
the uh hogs eat
we've spent billions of dollars helping
build facilities and supporting uh uh
facilities that manage this meat
industrial complex we've promoted it at
USDA uh you know we should be telling
people to eat less meat they're you know
they're told instead eat a balanced diet
which is at this point for most
Americans way out of balance way too
much animal protein so there's a
legislation that's been been introduced
that we hope becomes part of the farm
bill is this the this is the legislation
that was authored and sponsored by
Senator Booker and M and and Congressman
McGovern yeah and on the house side
great both great Champions um of En
environment and consumer health uh
low-income Assistance programs just uh
and and they're stepping into the farm
bill they're both on the agriculture
committees right you don't think of them
as a EG types but they they're there
because of the breath of this
jurisdiction so they've introduced the
plant-based uh the no the peas legumes
and nuts today act the plant act yeah
and I don't know how I feel about that
title I was I did a I did a podcast this
is a quick aside indulge me um but I had
uh Arnold Schwarz Niger on the podcast
the other day yeah and he's got a lot to
say about how we communicate in the
environmental space you know in terms of
how you connect with people and get them
excited language is important it is
important the plant Act is good how it
breaks down how it breaks down yeah yeah
it's a it's a it's a little yeah it's
corny so to speak but you know the the
the point is that we haven't begun to
invest in making sure that people who
are growing for this uh emerging sector
of plant-based foods that they're
getting the same potentially getting the
same Fair shake or same benefits that a
highly subsidized Farmers getting at
least don't don't tilt the field against
them um in rural areas where we have a
chance to invest in infrastructure uh
through loans and other means to help
plant-based food companies Spring up we
should be doing all of that so it's a
whole range of things in the bill and
it'll be a fight to get them in and get
money behind them um and so that you
know that's the it's a perfect example
of I mean most of your listeners are
probably not going to be
riled up necessarily about uh corn
Farmers getting too much money but what
they might get riled up about is the is
the prospect that if we don't if we
don't act in a fairer way we're not
going to have enough money we give it
all to the corn Farmers or soybean
Farmers we won't have enough for to
invest in uh organic transition to help
uh plant-based technology get better and
it needs to get better because some of
the products that are coming out now are
not very nutritious we should work on
that um we should be investing in um you
know all kinds of rural Enterprises that
will support this sector the that's it's
the it's the the fight over the money
really comes down to Bringing other
values to the table and having political
clout behind them to say hey you know
what we know you're going to get this
big piece of the pie we're going to try
and impose some limits on the biggest
recipients and do other things but but
we're also in there to say taxpayers
deserve a different Investment Portfolio
in agriculture than they get in this
farm bill and if you want to see what
that Port portfolio looks like go to the
farm subsidy database it'll take you
straight to ewg and you'll see all of
these Farmers getting money going back
to 85 sometimes tens of millions of
dollars for individual farming
operations they you know they ought to
be able to support themselves at this
point and we should be able to use some
of that money to improve the quality of
what we eat yeah it's certainly not
about maligning any you know the farming
Community or any individual Farmers it's
about innovating new ways to to disperse
that money and um some sense making
around you know the allocation of funds
um I have nothing but incredible
admiration and respect for Senator
Booker shouldering the responsibility of
of of you know kind of pushing this
forward in in interesting ways
um I find it to be very laudable and I
had the opportunity to um participate at
an event with him a couple weeks ago in
New Jersey at ethos Farm I don't know if
you've ever been to ethos Farm you heard
this far heard about it um but it's an
incredible regenerative Farm um where
this doctor Dr Weiss uh you know
purchased this land and also houses his
medical practice so his patients have to
come onto the farm to be seen and
treated and they are they are prescribed
the food that is grown on the farm it's
this food it's this sort of cyclical
food is medicine kind of system that's
really beautiful um but in spending the
weekend uh talking to and listening to
Senator Booker and and Dr Weiss I
learned a lot
about uh the challenges of of of trying
to operate one of these farms and I've
also visited Apricot Lane you know the
biggest little farm the Chesters yeah um
and and I couldn't help but think that
we need better resources and support
allocation for the regenerative movement
yeah because I think uh each and every
one of these um regenerative Farms seems
to be operating as an island onto itself
um and it's difficult right and very
tough but this is the this is the way we
need we need more of this we need more
energy we need we need you know funding
and we need I feel like you know if
somebody wants to convert their
conventional Farm into a regenerative
farm that you know a fleet of
Consultants show up uh to tell them
exactly how to do it and how to pave a
path towards economic viability forward
because it has to operate you know from
from a position of financially of course
Financial soundness obviously right um
but uh right now it's it feels like and
I don't I don't know you probably know
better than me that those resource are
lacking and I couldn't help but think as
you're talking about um the farm bill uh
that that that there's an opportunity to
take some of that funding and divert it
for that purpose that's right I mean you
know I I look I on the cook side of the
family my father's side there uh a lot
of farmers I spent a lot of time on my
uncle's cow CAF operations growing up um
I I get it and and when I go in tour
Farms I you know I I love the technology
I love how they're uh managing their
fields and it just blows my mind and the
level of financial responsibility they
have on top of the all the technology
they have to master I I got I got a lot
of time for a working farmer who's doing
that at whatever scale they're doing it
what this comes down to is is bringing a
different set of values and objectives
into the policy debate that wasn't there
before and you know the powers that be
don't like that um but that's a private
sector opportunity Perhaps it is yeah
but but I think Government Can can play
a role uh providing research providing
uh technical assistance providing uh
sometimes support for farming practices
that are regenerative that's what
climate smart farming has the potential
to do and we have billions of dollars uh
potentially to spend on over the next 10
years so it could really make a huge
impact we have to you know we have to
monitor it we can't assume that it's
going to make an impact until we know
for sure but that's really the that's
what Senator Booker and Jim McGovern and
lots of other reformers in the Congress
are talking about is let's let's take a
look at this money we've in invested and
again it's half a trillion dollars since
1995 and I defy you to find a place in
Rural America where you can really
definitely see the payoff off for that
huge investment and so it's fair for
people to ask you know The Outsiders
Urban folks or people who aren't large
Farmers but live in rural areas it's
fair for them to ask look um can't we do
better can't can't we do some try
something different we have all these
problems in Rural America we need jobs
uh the Farms that are getting bigger
we're musling people out of farming and
replacing them with chemicals and
Equipment
um whereas we still have a nutrition
crisis on our hands we need more fresh
food more closer to cities we need to
have new ways of growing food that
conserve soil replenish it um you know
build soil carbon where we can all of
these ideas deserve
consideration and we shouldn't just keep
spending money the way we have been on
you know right corn and back to the
incentive structure we need incentives
that would drive a farmer to make the
choice to convert his or her land into
regenerative practices we need you know
it's not just about supporting these
people it's like what are the macro
decisions that can be made that are
going to drive people towards the
solutions that we know work and pave a
better future yeah I mean from my
standpoint um this is where I think
consumers are really uh the more the
more we move in the direction where
these Foods become available and organic
is the perfect example the more that
pulls the sector along I I I'll talk
about it this way um organic you know
not too many years ago before it was a a
federal standard it was managed by the
states they all had their certification
programs and in 1990 a group of uh
people I was one of them got together
and we passed a law that established a
Federal standard it took over 10 years
to get the regulations out wow cuz there
was such opposition cuz the PRI you know
the the big players they didn't want
they didn't want a grocery store that
had one component that looked like it
was healthier or better than the other
that was the big talking point and our
view was why don't we just give people
choice so people seem to want organic
well now it's grown from a few hundred
million dollars to a 60 plus billion
dollar industry and and if that were the
only impact it would still be great but
there's a bigger impact which is you see
all over California now the influence of
organic growing techniques filtering
into conventional Farms they're using
different pesticides they're using them
differently in terms of timing uh we
still are way too addicted to pesticides
in the state of California where you
know the biggest fruit and vegetable
grower in the country as a state uh is
located but we can we can trace the the
impact that organic has had it's Prov
proven itself to in the marketplace it's
food that people want they're willing to
pay a little extra for and once you send
that signal you can't unsend it that
that's that when
regenerative becomes real and takes off
and is and and his you know has a set of
Standards behind it I think we'll begin
to see more widespread change we have a
ways to go on that but that's the key
and then the resources should follow um
you know we we should have a food system
if we're investing in it as taxpayers to
the tune of billions a year we should
have a a food system that's moving in
the direction that we want and the farm
bill is the place to do it and Cory
Booker and uh Jim McGovern and others
are they're gonna they're going to fight
and it's going to be a fight let me tell
you I've been in lots of them I this
will be I think my 11th farm bill and uh
people fight for every penny and it's
you know you just have to make the case
that look
um politics are such that if you want to
get this bill on through the floor of
the house and the floor of the Senate
you have to make some concessions to the
people who aren't on the ad committee
yeah that's the truth right
unfortunately yeah um I want to I want
to turn our attention to uh some
practical stuff yeah you know as I said
earlier obviously all of these things
lie in a spectrum um I want to help
people get their heads around um some
choice that they can make to snap them
out of whatever paralysis they might be
experiencing as a result of the
heaviness of all this subject matter um
if there's one thing that the ewg is
probably known for more than anything
it's the dirty dozen the dirty dozen of
course um I mean I I suspect like that
page on your website gets more traffic
than anything you probably have ever
done right like everybody people know
about this whether they are familiar
with ewg or not yeah it's everywhere
well the story of that is interesting um
this was back we we started doing this
really the thinking goes back 20
years we we were evaluating pesticides
in
produce and you know we looked at the
levels and we looked at the inadequate
regulations and we we basically felt
that people needed to know about
pesticides in their food and USDA
publishes data every year because they
test food MH so we were using those data
to rank the P the the the crops and the
pesticides and there are lots of
different ways you could do it we've
picked uh a couple of different ways but
the real insight was when we and I
credit my co-founder of ewg Richard WS
brilliant environmentalist and uh and
thinker uh who's now helping Sue oil
companies to hold them accountable so
he's continued his Brilliance Beyond ewg
but Richard had a very simple thought
which was well what about the people who
can't find or afford organic
as the alternative if you're worried
about pesticides and food and he was one
of the country's leading pesticide
experts at the time and we were very
tight with a guy named Phil landeron a
great Public Health doc a medical doctor
pediatrician um who uh has had a huge
impact on on public health and he's did
a lot of work on pesticides has done
over the years and he he once observed
to me you know can organic is like
private school for food now this is in
the early 2000s it's great if you can
find it great if you can afford it but
not everyone can so informed by that
Richard said well why don't we look at
the USDA test results and see if there
aren't some fruits and vegetables that
even if you can't find them organic at
least for the consumer we don't know
what's been sprayed in the field but at
least what's in the fruit or the
vegetable what are the pesticide levels
and so we did a
months and months of analyses and we
basically came out and said you know
there's a dirty dozen that you know
because it's alliterative if you can
find these organic you should find them
um if you're worried about pesticides
not everyone is but if you're worried
about it these sometimes they have you
know multiple pesticides on every batch
that that USDA
tested but there's another group of
fruits and vegetables that because of
timing of when they're sprayed remember
I mentioned that the oats are
contaminated with glyphosate but the
corn isn't because of the timing of the
spray oats are contaminated right before
harvest corn is sprayed before it's
hardly
sprouted the type of pesticides mattered
um the amount that was used and we saw
this this divide or this Continuum there
are lots of fruits and vegetables my
favorite example is always
bananas and I if you've been to Banana
plantations in the Caribbean or anywhere
else you know that they spray pesticides
on them they bag them in many cases and
spray pesticides there's a growing
organic b banana industry too
but but be but you peel it off it
doesn't those pesticides that they use
don't don't penetrate the Flesh of the
fruit so bananas and a few others in
that list were clean so we just said
look our our job here is to give choices
to people who have these concerns and
they're not crazy to have the concerns
you're not crazy to be worried about
these chemicals in your life industry
will tell you don't worry about it
you're not crazy and we went over some
of the scientific organizations that if
it's crazy then they're
crazy we just decided let's let's lay it
out there and tell people here's here's
the dirty dozen apples are always on
there strawberries are always on there a
few others that occur you know peaches
often times because it's tough to grow
peach bees in Georgia without using
pesticides so they tend to have more
pesticides on them and then there's this
whole uh 15 set of uh fruits and
vegetables that are pretty clean even if
they're not organic it was that industry
went crazy they accused us of scaring
consumers um and you know accused us of
uh trying to force organic down
everyone's throats when really what we
were trying to say is look this is
information that's been developed by EPA
the government's not going to act on it
some of these pesticides have been on
the market for 40 years um and then
suddenly they're off when EPA wakes up
or does the right thing but meanwhile
you can avoid them you can avoid them
with conventional food so get the dirty
dozen guide for pesticides and produce
and on the back of it is the Clean 15
it's a little card and and that alone
that was our introduction Rich to the to
the power of consumers to change
markets because people were saying thank
you I can't I where I live I don't have
organic but I'm I'm shopping from this
Clean 15 side of your card now uh or I
you know I I can find organic some of
the year but not you know I'm not crazy
about berries whatever it might be that
they had organic options for that wasn't
working for them either this gave them a
choice and it also reinforced our
philosophy at ewg which is we're about
trying to give you choices we'll give
you the information we're not going to
wag our finger at you if you're not 100%
organic we're not going to wag our
finger at you if you don't you know
haven't gone through your whole house
and replaced every item that we've
identified that has chemicals in it we
live in the real world too and we don't
want you to move to a yurt in a mountain
Meadow and think that's the only place
you can survive we want to give you
options for the real world so take a
look at your food supply take our look
at our food scores Page look at
processed foods there we rate the
nutrition we call out the contam am
minant look at the dirty dozen look at
our shoppers guide that's the equivalent
for personal care products skin deep in
all of those areas we've really tried to
do our best to empower consumers who
live in the real world and we you know
if you can give up five Personal Care
items because you've just been pring too
much in front of the mirror that's good
but if you're going to use some personal
care items here here are some options
that are are healthier in our view right
and I would encourage everybody to go to
the website ewg.org um and there you
have just a Litany of these reports and
you can search by product by category
and find all kinds of resources to help
guide those choices so everybody has
their
homework uh and and that homework can be
as extensive as as you would like
because you have almost an unlimited you
know sort of database there but in terms
of synopsizes that you know before we
kind of round this out we talked about
the dirty dozen and the Clean 15 in the
food category but if a mom is worried
about the products that uh that she's
going to lather on her infant or you
know somebody's thinking about the
shampoo or the the face cleanser that
they're using yeah sunscreen that's a
whole thing right um what are just some
top level um you know point you'd like
to make about the bigger harms that you
can avoid that can drive the healthier
choices when you go to the store yeah
well first of all start in one area and
work your way out you don't have to
change everything at once don't punish
yourself um make make this gamify it you
know make make it something where you
give yourself some a pat on the back for
some wins so start with food start with
our food scores database um go through
your don't throw out your food food eat
the food these are chronic risks eat the
food you've already bought and paid for
but when you shop again shop a little
smarter those all that Captain Crunch
and the the conventionally grown oatmeal
Su the sugar stuff is a little different
yeah but even but even that I mean you
may want to throw it out maybe you can
afford to throw it out um but but it is
a chronic a chronic risk so what we're
basically saying is overtime you need to
make these changes know this also um I
mean
whether you start with
food whether you start on our skin de
database with your personal care items
um what I can tell you from our
experience over the past certainly 20
years of our 30 years of existence
things are changing there are options
out there now that were not there
certainly 10 years ago but in many cases
five years ago the impact smart healthy
Shoppers are having in the marketplace
is profound we hear it every day
companies are struggling in some cases
to reformulate uh some of them are
coming into our program and
reformulating their products completely
because they want our seal some of them
are just doing it because they want to
score better in skin deep or one of our
other systems
and that's the that's what you should
feel hopeful about every time you make a
better choice you send a signal to the
Marketplace economy that safer choices
are a good thing make more of them and
these Executives move around from
company to company they see consumer
Trends in food and they might go to work
for a uh you know a restaurant chain or
they might go to work for a personal
care product or a cleaning product
company they have this in their head
that transparency from the internet
source of of information like ewg and
there are others out there we're proud
of ours but there are others out out
there is is starting to drive
changes uh at such a scale that
companies are adapting and whole markets
are changing what we're seeing with
sunscreens you know for oxybenzone was
in all sunscreens now it's dramatically
reduced we started working on sunscreens
pretty much alone 20 years ago um and we
raised concerns about oxybenzone for
health and also for the impact that was
the studies were emerging on on Coral
and it's moving out of sunscreens
so my view is that if you are a
conscious consumer and find sources you
trust you can verify we welcome anyone
to come to ewg and if you have questions
send us the questions but once you do
that um and start changing your
behavior I'm not telling you you won't
get cancer I'm not telling you your your
child won't develop a rash that's all
still you know
much much too granular to predict from
this level of this conversation or from
our databases what I can tell you is
that the aggregate impact of those
consumer purchases is changing the
economy and that's hopeful and and when
someone and this is my my maybe my
closing point when young people come to
me now and ask me um for career advice
you know when I was coming up I wanted
to be Ralph nater and the was you know
pretty narrow go to law school join a
public interest group go into government
be a
crusader and I still strongly recommend
people take a look at at Public Service
in some form or another whether it's
non-governmental or or wherever but I I
tell people now look there are so many
companies out there where creativity and
a drive to do things better and
differently sustainably in
health that is such an exciting
development just in in you know my
professional life take a look at that
too maybe go to business school and try
and change the world that way maybe
maybe you know devote yourself to
Athletics and and from that bring this
enormous crowd around a healthier living
and plant-based diets you know there's
lots of ways into this just take that
first
step yeah I would I would uh only add to
that the hopefulness that I've seen and
experience when I speak to young people
who are making career decisions based
upon um their ability to drive
meaningful impact and that's also a
seismic shift from the mental calculus
of my generation around which careers to
pursue um which I think is amazing and
bodess well for the future and I think
on top of that um there's something
beautifully
empowering um and agency instilling
about realizing that your choice can and
does make a difference in the sense or
in the same way that that change comes
to Washington uh consumer choices Drive
Capital markets so it's easy to point a
finger and say they want you sick or
they want this and that or whatever
but these industries respond to what
people want and we have seen a shift in
what people want and the choices they're
making around food food skin care Etc
everything that we've talked about today
and that has moved the market in ways
that probably might even astonish you
who steeped in this right do so within
that there is that place of hope and
within the hope there's agency um and
and and also uh you know a
responsibility um to be more mindful
about those choices because each choice
is a vote that you're casting for it
matters the better world of your
imagination right and there are things
that you can do and you are providing
the resources to help guide those
choices we're certainly trying and and
you know what it all comes down to when
I started out um you know in the in the
in the 70s really as a working
environmentalist
um the whole the whole goal the whole
framing was around what we were
against what we had tried to stop things
that were going wrong things that needed
to end we need to stop Paving over
Wilderness areas we need to you know
stop building dams we need to stop
erecting petrochemical plants and stop
spraying so many pesticides on and on
the whole
environmental
framework and it's it makes sense damage
control as opposed to Future casting now
it's shifting to what we're for mhm and
it's that's what's so exciting to me
about environmentalism now is as it's
expressed often in the private sector
not only but often in the private sector
there's there's a way for you to be for
something that can make change happen uh
again much more rapidly and much more
deeply than any government regulation
ever could we are changing the power
sector here in this country now um not
primarily through regulation we're we're
greening the power sector with resources
that are being offered to utilities and
other companies to build electric
vehicles uh green up the grid and so
forth big pressure on these utilities to
deal with um distributed solar and other
sources of energy because those are
competitors well this all came about
because public interest groups working
with people in the private sector said
hey we can do this in a different way
we're we're for energy but just this
kind of energy we're for energy
generation but not generated that way we
don't want coal plants we want solar
panels we want we want windmills that
being for something is so obviously
positive and uplifting of of human
nature and young people that I'm I'm
excited about environmentalism now even
though um we obviously are still up
against it it's a dire time yeah but the
key that unlocks all of it is it not
is is uh creating and convincing people
that it is the most economically viable
solution to the problem they face right
when the green choice is actually the
best economic choice that's when the
problems at the macro level get solved
and the decision makers come on board
right and we're seeing more and more of
that with these companies that are
established upon this set of values when
they succeed it creates greater success
or a path for success for these other
companies and I think being able to
communicate that message to to Governor
Schwarzenegger's Point totally is really
important especially in terms of of
developing consensus and the bipartisan
support that's necessary at those
legislative and Regulatory levels to to
make the decisions that we need in order
you know to perpetuate the groundwell of
movement from the bout the bottom up
yeah and it's got to be bottom up um and
that's why it you know whenever you see
this this positive connection to you
know being able to make change happen
and create The New
Normal economically and socially um not
not through regulation again I my my my
folks are fighting for regulation every
day don't get me wrong we're we're at
EPA we're at in uh you know in
Sacramento wherever the case may be we
haven't given up that fight we're still
against a lot of bad stuff but this way
of approaching solving environmental
problems now that has the cultural throw
weight we didn't have before is what is
what makes a difference that that you
know you you can't plausibly say as a
utility
executive that uh solar panels are uh
kind of a hobby anymore you can't say
that organic is you know it's it's fine
if you're into that but it's not a big
deal you can't say that uh cleaning
products that have dramatically lower
off gassing uh are uh you know an oddity
they're not this is all happening and so
the the folks who are listening to to
this thank you for listening first of
all um but and thank you for modeling so
much of this rich in in all that you do
but the fact of the matter is we can
make this we can make this progress only
if we do it intentionally and make all
those small decisions just add that
little that little twist of of agency
and say I'm gonna you know I'm GNA buy
this instead of this I'm gonna support
this instead of this and move the ball
forward that way beautifully put I think
that's a a great place to put a pin in
it for today than brother yeah thank you
I appreciate it um I think the work you
do is is is just so meaningful and
powerful and uh you were eloquent and
how you explained all of that today I'm
at your service um if people want to
learn more about you and ewg obviously
go to ewg.org um and if they want to get
involved if they want to support what is
the best way best way is um you know we
get on our email list find out what
we're up to sometimes we're fighting it
out in California sometimes in um in DC
sometimes we're just sending you our
latest tips our latest science we have
have a paper coming out out had a paper
just came out that looked at uh off
gassing of chemicals from home cleaning
products that was I opening another
nightand reading before you go yeah but
you know you can you can a little shop a
little change in your shopping cart and
those chemicals go away those exposure
events are gone from your life and that
sends that signal to the market hey
people want more of this less of that
all right man thanks so much take come
back and share a little more with me
anytime anytime cheers peace Lance
[Music]
that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way
as well as the plant power meal planner
at meals. roll.com if you'd like to
support the podcast the easiest and most
impactful thing you can do is to
subscribe to the show on Apple podcasts
on Spotify and on YouTube and leave a
review and or comment supporting the
sponsors who support the show is also
important and appreciated and sharing
the show or your favorite episode with
friends or on social media is of course
awesome and very helpful and finally for
podcast updates special offers on books
the meal planner and other subjects
please subscribe to our newsletter which
you can find on the footer of any page
at Rich roll.com Today's show was
produced and engineered by Jason Cameo
with additional audio engineering by
Kale Curtis the video edition of the
podcast was created by Blake Curtis with
assistance by our creative director Dan
Drake portraits by Davey Greenberg
graphic social media assets courtesy of
Daniel CIS thank you Georgia Wy for
copywriting and website management and
of course our theme music was created by
Tyler Patt Traer Patt and Harry matis
appreciate the love love the support see
you back here soon peace
plance
[Music]
namaste
he